only on cbs mornings we are revealing a
massive new push to make covet vaccines
more accessible particularly in poorer
parts of the world and it involves a
familiar face academy award winner
charlie stern is teaming up with the
ford foundation to fight vaccine
misinformation and inequality and cobit
vaccine rate is less than four percent
in africa where she was born darren told
jonathan vigliotto how her organization
the charlize theron africa outreach
project is helping
as a fellow woman
i feel so inspired charlize theron's
africa outreach program
has been fighting to prevent the spread
of hiv aids among south africa's
adolescent population since 2007
have members with your organization
spoken with those on the ground in south
africa who are hesitant to get those
vaccines because of misinformation that
they've heard
yes i mean we've seen misinformation
with hiv so it's not new to us it's in
finding that right community based
health worker that will be able to sit
down with somebody and speak to them in
a language they understand and they know
her because they see her down the street
farron is now channeling her
organization's grassroots network in the
fight against covid just 14 percent of
south africa's population of 60 million
is fully vaccinated we have to remember
that we're talking about families when
we see the devastation that covet 19 has
caused us personally here in america
it's so much worse in countries like
south africa
the global pandemic has exposed how
public health care systems are failing
marginalized populations only one third
of the promised doses of the vaccine
have been delivered to africa these
viruses will not go away until we
actually look at social injustices we
value certain lives more than others and
until that goes away
we will never get to the end of diseases
like hiv or covid we're about to walk
into one of our mobile clinics that's
working in this area today i don't know
how not to be an optimist if i didn't
think that there was hope for any of the
stuff i would just stay in bed because i
love my bed that human spirit that we
all have how you see people survive
things that are unimaginable is what
gives me hope because i've seen people
come out on the other side because we
can do this we actually can
for cbs mornings i'm jonathan vigliotti
in los angeles
[Applause]
in a time op-ed today theron and ford
foundation president darren walker
called on world leaders to take action
darren walker joins us right now darin
good morning how are you doing great
thank you thanks for coming now
president biden says the u.s will send
more than 1 billion vaccine doses to
other countries is that enough no it's
not enough while we're encouraged by the
administration's
urgent call to action we need more
vaccines
delivered to the developing world so one
billion is a great start but we need a
multiple of that number what more can
the u.s do what the u.s can do is to
work with the other g20 nations
to organize a collective action to
mobilize the financing this is going to
take tens of billions of dollars we've
got to come up with the financing for
that we have to work on the supply we
have a challenge of of creating enough
vaccines for the rest of the world and
finally we have to work on distribution
once the vaccines land in a country that
doesn't mean that they're going to be
distributed equitably to all communities
so we have to focus on all three of
those dimensions is that what the 15
million dollar
in ford foundation grants is going to be
doing what you just laid out there and
will any part of it go toward addressing
vaccine hesitancy which of course is not
only a problem here in america it is in
other countries as well absolutely
vaccine hesitancy is a major challenge
misinformation and disinformation and
and across the african continent
is real just as it is in the united
states and so we'll be making grants to
grassroots organizations it's one of the
things that we've been doing with
charlize's foundation working with
grassroots this has to be a grassroots
and a grass tops strategy i'm looking at
you and charlize darren a new power
couple i'd say did she reach out to you
did you reach out to her how did this
partnership come about well i first met
charlize five years ago in durban at an
hiv conference
both the ford foundation and charlize's
foundation have been working on aids in
hiv for well over a decade and it was
really through collaborating on that
work many of the same grassroots
organizations community-based
organizations working on hiv and aids in
africa are the same ones working now on
on vaccines what frustrates you the most
as we sit here today you know i always
marvel that here in this country we
still have people that won't take the
vaccine and you look at other countries
that would kill to get what we're having
despite all the misinformation and
disinformation people still want this
vaccine and we're just sitting here
watching it pile up aren't we well what
frustrates me the most gail is that
today there are millions of doses of
vaccines sitting in refrigerators
in europe in the united states
and in much of the developing world
people are desperate to be vaccinated
and so the inequality the global
inequality that is manifest in that
reality
deeply troubles me
do you feel like people of influence or
shall i say individuals of color in
positions of influence are doing enough
to speak up for what the vaccine can do
for this country i think as americans
we've been focused on our own country
and that's understandable but we are
quickly finally
making tremendous progress so we now
ought to be able to turn to the rest of
the world
we are known uh americans as the most
generous people on the planet
so let us be generous
in this moment
and it's bigger than covid19 isn't it
you think you you say we need to look
beyond covert 19. for future issues
absolutely the reality here is that we
cannot inoculate ourselves and believe
that uh by being vaccinated in this
country
we are immune because the rest of the
world if we don't see we've seen with
delta
delta came from another part of the
world where there was a prevalence of of
non-vaccinated people we're going to see
the same thing the experts tell us there
will be new variants
if the rest of the world is not
vaccinated right well we appreciate you
sounding the alarm darren walker good to
have you at the table thank you thank
you thank you so much